The one commodity that is most valuable
on this earth is time,
time to love cancer live from the moment
the human body is born,
it begins dying.
I don't think you need quite caught
that.
Let me say it again.
From the moment the human body is born,
it begins dying.
Some happening faster,
some happening slower.
Some of US help them happy,
go faster.
Some of them prevented from happening
sooner than later.
Coach high coming to you live on the
field of life.
How many seconds?
How many minutes do we waste every day?
Doing things that are no where near the
goals and aspirations and passions that
we have inside.
How many times are you go through the
course of a day and realize,
did I do anything I set out to do today?
Write down those goals each and every
day.
No matter if there's two goals a day.
If you can accomplish those,
then you're doing more than just making
it through the day you are living and
achieving your dreams.
You know as inspirational speakers,
we don't want to just talk to you.
We want to live that as well.
I've done that in my life as well.
Find time to better yourself.
Read,
explore research,
live life,
do things you've never thought of doing
before.
That's what it's all about.
When you're born.
That's their date that they put on the
left side of the tombstone.
When you die,
they put another date on the right side
of the tombstone,
but that dash in the middle is the most
important thing on that tombstone.
That is alone.
Then throughout that entire time frame,
you were able to impact and touch others
lives.
You were able to leave your mark on this
earth.
You were able to build a legacy there.
Nobody could change.
You were able to have it to where people
remember who you are,
no matter what you're living for that
dash in the middle,
you're going to remember your why,
your why.
Why are you here,
not,
not the why.
Why did you do something your why,
your your reason for getting up in the
morning,
your reason for pushing yourself past
the brink of exertion and giving up your
reason for moving on and and getting
things done in life.
That dash in the middle.
That's the thing that pushes you.
Just this stop for a second.
Write down your why.
What,
what are you doing this for in life?
If your why doesn't make you cry and
that's not your why.
Again,
if your why doesn't make you cry the
last,
not your why,
your why should be something so big that
it moves your family tree.
Your why should be something so big that
it changes the whole outlook on how
things are with you and your home,
your family,
your religion,
your purpose.
Think about your passion,
okay.
Thinking about your opportunities and
that's how you find your purpose.
OPP.
Yeah.
When that y meets up with your passion,
your opportunity,
your purpose,
then you'll find out the most important
day in your life is the day you remember
why you were born.
Okay.